as one of her wishes I should sooner
than later though because this is the
third time and usually the third time
kind of tells you that you know what I
mean you gotta trust your gut I got a
Kelly Rowland is ready to make amends
with her strange father for the sake of
her son you're raising one of our next
leaders Titan is such an adorable little
nugget thank you and obviously it takes
a village to raise your son and you said
recently that you wanted to reach out to
your dad to have them be a part of your
son's life have you done that yet I have
not done that no hardly what are the
hesitations fair I mean I think that
it's just opening Pandora's box for
something like that and everyone around
me tells me to because they don't want
it to be too late and I won't get the
opportunity so yeah it definitely has to
happen right you're there like the third
person asked me that so that's just so
weird that lies that I have to do it I
have to do it literally makes my stomach
turn oh just thinking about it that's so
crazy
well you know what all family died meant
all families have their dynamics
salutely but did you talk to your mom
about possibly doing that before she
passed yes as a matter of fact she
wanted me to do that and the universe is
telling it to me too so
it's time when the singer is not
spending time with her family she's
serving the community so you're a mother
you're a philanthropist and now you're
out here with the Boys and Girls Club
how are you how are you helping with
them today and why are you a longtime
supporter of the club or the Boys and
Girls Clubs of America have partnered
with Lowe's we are actually taking this
initiative to revitalize some of our
Boys and Girls Clubs of America as you
can imagine kids are allowed to be
themselves in this space and sometimes
they get a little while take so some of
our clubs are gonna get a little beat up
but um the kids are are allowed to be
kids like I said and they are our future
leaders we are sowing into them the type
of seeds that we're sowing into young
people they're so important because in a
time especially now we need some leaders
mm-hmm we need some leaders who you know
are Colin Kaepernick's
you know I'm gonna speak out it they're
going to speak out and
and be courageous and bold and know who
they are as people in this world that's
so big that and I'm just so proud to be
a part of the family
[Music]